the Geoghan experience Dana White says
kymaro Othman vs. Jorge Maz with all
planned for international fight week don
don da yeah they just had a little [ __ ]
the Superbowl um I thought I was wrong
too I'm a [ __ ] idiot I thought it was
going to be Connor against Moscow no
that's how I thought the next fight was
gonna be that's a great fight that's a
great fight I think Connor really wants
khabib and Dana's keep saying they're
gonna try to make a rematch but I don't
know why they're saying that when khabib
has to fight Tony
yes [ __ ] Ferguson yeah Tony's
the boogeyman that nicknamed el Cucuy
that's a perfect nickname for that guy
that guy's terrifying he never gets
tired no he never gets tired everybody
who fights it looks like they fell off a
train it's it's crazy that's the fight
everybody has wanted to see and again is
that March or April cuz if kind of row
okay yeah that's still a ways away and
then who knows how that FICO is how long
it takes to get better it bent khabib
doesn't want to have anything to do with
Conor he's like [ __ ] that dude and cubes
dad said give him a hundred million
dollars we'll fight him yeah yeah so I
don't think you can make a hundred
million dollars the only way it could
make a hundred million dollars is if it
gets the kind of numbers that Floyd
Mayweather vs Conor God or if the UFC
decides to bankroll it and gamble and
give him a hundred million dollars I
mean they might do that because here's
one thing we have to take any
consideration about khabib he's not just
an enormous star in the United States
he's a huge superstar in the Muslim you
know huge huge he's a super religious
guy I mean he celebrates Ramadan he's
you know that's he's very respectful
this is one of the reasons why Conor's
trash-talking all that was so
infuriating to him he's a different guy
man he's a man of virtue still drives a
[ __ ] Toyota he's worth millions and
millions of dollars he's not he's not a
flashy dude he's a [ __ ] warrior and
he doesn't want to have that kind of
situation again in his eyes they fought
once he smashed Conor and he got him he
got him to tap I choked him and he's
like good I did it fights over
I did what I want to do [ __ ] you you
know and when they were saying god we
need to make a rematch no no no we had
the fight I [ __ ] him up he can suck my
dick
I'm gonna go do other things I know
that's that's that's what he's thinking
I think not the sock the deck part yeah
yeah just yeah
I think khabib versus Tony is the
toughest fight of Cubs career I really
believe that I think Tony Ferguson is a
nightmare for anybody especially right
now
when you watch his fight with Anthony
Pettis when you watch how he busted up
Donald Cerrone I think Tony Ferguson is
the scariest guy for anybody at 155
pounds to fight he doesn't get tired he
[ __ ] has bricks for hands and I had
Josh Thompson in here the other day
Josh was saying when could when Tony
Ferguson grabs him he said you can't
believe how big his hands are
he's a gg wraps his hands around his
wrists I couldn't get my hands-free he
goes these [ __ ] hands are so big and
strong in his presence I don't know
Halloween yeah he's a spooky dude
there's something about Mike he ain't
normal
he's not a normal guy he's eccentric but
in the good way yeah like especially
when it comes to being a fighter he does
all his own training he teaches him so
like he's got all this crazy [ __ ] he
does where he does like Wing Chun
dummies and break dances
there's a lot of [ __ ] that not me on the
video did you see the video he put out
kind of a Tony Ferguson tribute workout
video and the gym Tony's a he's a unique
individual there's no other Tony
Ferguson there's no one that I could
even think of that reminds me of Tony
Ferguson no one he's so different you
know that said khabib 'he's the [ __ ]
man I mean no one runs through people
the way khabib does he smashes people he
drags him to the ground he out wrestles
him he pummels only beats him down you
know he's an undeniable unstoppable
force the two of them together it's an
epic fight but I would not be making any
plans if I was Dana or if I was anybody
else I would not be making any plans
because khabib can win that fight yeah
could be I mean Ferguson yeah Tony can
win that fight to either one of those
guys
I mean I'm to be can win that fight but
it's not guaranteed Tony can win that
fight too Ferguson can win that fight
they both can win I just want the fight
to happen this is is this the fourth or
fifth time it's in schedule I just want
the fight to happen I mean everybody
knows you're telling me I'm just begging
and pleading that these guys keep it
together could only hope only hope and
pray they keep it together
it's a [ __ ] amazing fight man amazing
and Caitlyn is fired what is she
fighting Valentina
I know her but I'm not gonna do it till
yeah she's a coming for a jumper yeah
that's a dangerous fight that's a
dangerous fight for her Valentina scary
yes she is she's a killer
that woman's a killer
[Applause]